[Music]
[Laughter]
we are here hey
what's up it's fight night round two we
have the sfx
and a new upstart is coming at the king
however
we are 10 years prior
and uh 15 years prior if you're talking
about the first time that this essay was
delivered
but derrida pits himself
against king foucault his old teacher
sounds like a dragon ball z name
actually a little bit can't say i was
ever much of a dragon ball z dude
i mean if you called him king foku it
would it would work even better
well i don't know if you guys are using
the copy that i'm using but this is uh
writing indifference chapter two
otherwise you can find it
as the kogito and the history of madness
is that what it's called
yeah so this is fight night round two
where we pit one philosopher's
criticisms
against another try to give the best
case for it
last week we did bodria and foucault
1977. this is
derrida against foucault 1967
from a lecture that he gave in 1963 at
the ripe age of 33 years old early
thirties
[ __ ] precocious bastard yep
yep last week seemed it went to the
judges
the page what did they think they they
gave it to bodria
i think all the ones that decided to uh
throw their score in but i don't think
that was decisive
as much as this one this one to me felt
like a knockout like i i forgot yeah
after reading this essay yeah i kind of
agree i agree
yeah well we have yet to uh speak in
fuco's defense
actually we've really been on the
offensive quite a bit
that's true next next week he'll defend
himself
next week in a paper that he wrote
against our back against
derrida defending himself but i've never
read that one to be fair i've always
found
it is easier to criticize someone than
to put forward an original idea of your
own
and obviously and bojarov both put
forward very original ideas of their own
but at this point they're just
essentially taking pot shots at the
master so i think it is important to
take that
keep that in mind right didn't i hear
this essay was the first one where he
drops the concept of difference
in print one of the first print moments
i think it is
i noticed it in there and he didn't
explain it at all but we should say
that foucault at this point had only
published one of his major texts which
was
uh help me out here what was it a
history of madness
history of madness so he's not god
foucault
yet he's still uh working his way up the
up the ladder he's prince he's prince
and he's still he's still heir to the
throne you know because he's still got
sartre running around that guy needs to
be taken down a peg
we got levi strauss who was uh kind of
like the king of structuralism in the
60s before uh
derrida also had his way with him in uh
was it 1968 and
uh i think we actually might have did we
read that essay
i mean giving foucault's propensity to
like bdsm saying have his way with him
countries a lot of interesting imagery
there well we already know that
foucault's sexuality does not exist
because told us last week that's right
oh yeah
we we read uh derrida's essay earlier
on um was it on structure and difference
or something that the essay he
wrote specifically for that 68
conference
where um levy strauss was sort of
the guest of honor and he was presenting
his big sort of structuralist paradigm
and darida kind of wrote this i think it
was like an inaugural address or
something like that in 68 and he kind of
laid out post-structuralism there and
you can almost see
the seeds of it in here i i actually
recognized some of the turns of phrase
he was using in this essay
yeah and you can see his strategy
develop here too it's
pick out pick out a few lines that he
thinks are supposedly
on the margins of the text and then
reading the whole rest of the text
through that little
marginal comment what's interesting
about this too is um
eric and i were talking about this in
the chat is how much
weight um he puts on foco's
interpretation of
descartes uh and normally that would be
fairly trivial since obviously you know
you kind of hone in on a great thinker
that you assume people will be familiar
with in order to kind of
raise relevant points but i think import
it's important to situate this
historically since this is the moment
in french philosophy and i suppose you
could say european or western whichever
you prefer
philosophy as a whole uh where the
cartesian subject really comes
under fire from all directions you know
the shots had been fired before
by the heideggers the hegels the niches
whoever you want before
but by this point almost everybody
starts to decide that
we need to do away with this in one way
shape or form uh
and so i think it's really interesting
that both of them are kind of wrestling
with descartes legacy
uh in these texts and they ascribe such
significance to that
but neither of them uh seems willing to
endorse what it is that descartes
was trying to do even if i think daradat
interestingly is a little bit more
friendly to descartes
than fukuoka was yeah i this was written
in the early 60s 63 when
he first gave it as a lecture but i find
that today
i have not done i used to do it and i
have not done it for about five years
but i
hate when people just bring up descartes
to
take some pot shots and be like oh it's
not like the whole world doesn't exist
not like descartes thinks we're not
doing mind-body dualism
which if you read descartes or who's
sorel on descartes
that even that wasn't even the point of
of the meditations
no but i mean like ggx said this in the
ticular subject i think it was 1997
uh where he said he was bored of the
whole debate over the philosophy of the
subject and cartesian
um rationality he said everybody now
doesn't believe in it
everyone just assumes it's a kind of
bygone paradigm so of course jesus being
dnac is like i'm gonna bring it back
you know i'm gonna make it sexy again so
i think we've all moved past
the kind of debate a little bit uh where
most people will accept that they're
huge problems with the cartesian cogito
ego some but you won't see people
attacking it as
venomously as maybe they once would have
um yeah so yeah i think it's just
important to
take note of that since you know there's
there's a reason why it is that they're
both battling over his legacy so
intensely it's a historical interest i
think
well if you've been to grad school and i
know you have
it's a shorthand for things i don't like
is cartesian said there's something
wrong with the world yeah it's cartesian
rationality what was the old phrase you
know from plato to nato
through descartes right sure i mean i
feel like descartes is not even really
like the boogeyman anymore in
in philosophy departments it's more like
i don't know what's it called
logical positivism or something is like
the straw man that people like to uh be
put themselves in opposition i mean that
that started up really in the in the
90s with the science wars or positivism
was
in direct opposition to the new social
constructivist
methods but in the in the history of
philosophy
i think rorty said something like this
or to this effect is that
after descartes it's all really just
either a position on or against
descartes but that that's what i wanted
us to ask just to like preempt this
because
eric i know you have your problems with
descartes i know that i have my problems
with descartes having read heidegger
uh but before we you know before we dive
into this text
anybody want to say something about
descartes that they think is
interesting or do they draw anything
from the card let's go on the circle and
say
one nice thing yeah well just so that
you know we offer an all branch to it
because i
actually think what's interesting about
this text to me and i'll explain why is
that
i actually expected that darada would
have been much more critical of
descartes um
than foucault would have uh and yet i
think his interpretation is a lot more
charitable and it kind of sets the tone
for his work going forward because
for all there it is put forward as this
kind of boogeyman of western
civilization just deconstructing
everything
he is known for the kind of charity of
his readings of a lot of figures you
know he really loved the history of
philosophy
and he rarely just goes in to trash
somebody uh except for
co in this case well he wrote at the
there's a quotation in the last
couple pages here and he says uh
foucault's reading
is naive yeah so foucault
took offense to that of course because
foucault takes offense to everything
he's
kind of a [ __ ] that way he didn't talk
to daredev for 20 years until
uh derrida was arrested on a charge of
weed possession actually in prague
bad boy
i mean what a bastard considering all
the weird [ __ ] up [ __ ] that was going
on in czechoslovakia at that time i
can't believe that that was what they
decided to focus on but whatever
and we should mention also that uh
derrida was
foucault's student about five years
before this and he writes that at the
beginning
i am the disciple trying to uh come at
the master
i like the idea of dairydoc smoking weed
though it's it's kind of nice
to think about so let me just answer
that question about
about descartes i guess i would say that
descartes is like a fun person to start
undergrad philosophy with because you
get to
ask fun questions about like skepticism
and how sure you can be about
knowledge and it's like a good way to
set the stage for an undergrad
philosophy class yeah i agree with that
i mean descartes method was was
revolutionary
and it i mean they say in the history of
philosophy
one the one of the best things descartes
ever did was to get everyone to stop
reading the scholastics
and to stop that's true using the
authorities
the combined authorities of the church
and
a christianized aristotle to answer
every single question
like use your own reason use
logic think for yourself like
in a way derrida or not terry dev uh
descartes message was like a proto
version of that
you know you use the light of your own
reason to work out issues don't rely
on the church fathers and the ancient
authorities because and almost as if to
to uh justify this opinion you know
galileo overturns the whole
institution of aristotelian physics soon
after
and you have the enlightenment getting
going and you know
here we are today with descartes sort of
at the very very
beginning of that movement so you know
whatever bad things you can find to say
about descartes i mean he was a
pivotal figure quite brilliant even if
he wrote
his philosophy alone locked in a room
with that had to be like a very specific
temperature
that's not true satan was there remember
yeah
no satan could have been there a church
could have been there he
he was a he was a phenomenally important
figure in
history and yeah i agree also with
victor
okay this is supposed to be fight night
so let's fast forward
from the uh early 17th century
30 years war let's fast forward to uh
post heidegger where the biggest insult
is
you're doing metaphysics no you're doing
metaphysics
and in this essay derrida accuses
foucault of doing metaphysics
then there's de les who's like [ __ ] yeah
i'm doing metaphysics what are you going
to do about it yeah i was just going to
say i was so
well that i mean that brings up the
question because you know i didn't uh i
haven't read the foucault
uh text that's being referenced here or
at least not all of it i think i read
sections of it in
maybe my master's but i'm wondering if
if if anyone can clarify right like what
is the use of descartes in
foucault that is kind of the focus that
i feel like that would be a good
starting point right like let's get
clear on what is foucault claiming
about descartes that is then becomes the
thing that darida
ends up getting fixated on in this essay
well i should say
history of madness in an age of
civilization the way it's usually
published here
uh is a much abridged version of the
book um that poco ultimately published
which was
this massive tome uh analyzing you know
the history of
rationality and the transition you know
to kind of medicalize cognition that we
see in modernity uh you know the history
of madness uh
or madness and civilization sorry it's
usually published as like a 200-page
book here
uh but like the fundamental thesis is
really quite striking right which is
that
reason you know as we understand in the
modern world isn't something that's
transparently obvious it had to be
constructed and was constructed via this
long process of eventually demarcating
itself from everything that because
comes considered unreason and in many
ways uh
foucault sees descartes as one of if not
the pivotal figures
and this transition right uh and what
comes across in the book
uh and this is why it focuses on madness
uh is that of course
because useful co uh this demarcation
between reason
and its other uh entails the
construction of a new system of power he
doesn't quite call it power knowledge
yet
but it's pretty clear what he's getting
at right since of course the people who
assume the authority to say what's
reasonable
also assume the authority to demarcate
who's unreasonable
and of course to police their
epistemology their ontology
their moral sensibilities more or less
everything which is why
the mad becomes such a significant
figure for him right
since they're kind of the paradigmatic
unreasonable figure who stands astride
or against
uh the modernist impulse uh to allow
reason to tyrannize everything or a
certain
concept of reason to tyrannize
everything i mean it's an overstated
thesis but i mean you read the book it's
very classical codes very well written
it's very dramatic lots of pulpy
historical examples
it is an innovative reading of descartes
since nobody would have i think
ascribed that to him in quite as vivid
away as he would but
i think it's actually just a straight up
wrong reading of descartes
this essay it definitely shows but yeah
i agree madness has always been
only spoken about or theorized by
the rational and then in this case it's
instrumentalized
state sanctioned psychiatry
and psychiatrists uh are not seen as
interpreters
of madness they're seen as scientists
of madness and that's right of reason
that's where you see this origin of
power knowledge because they have
knowledge then they are
able to speak for the mad and then the
mad
mad people insane people
institutionalized people on the other
hand are compelled into silence by nurse
ratchet
so the history of madness is then the
history of the silent side
of this duality between reason and
madness so
all right project sounds good kart
obviously has
problems with it and i should say it's
meticulously researched right again
the little 200 page book that we get
here is nothing compared to like the
[ __ ]
beefy i can't even remember how seven or
eight hundred pages long yeah
like it's it's not like a co toss this
off on a weekend
i believe it's 673 to be exact
there you go like it's magisterial and
it makes additions to it in the 70s
so what is so what is the claim then
that's being that that that uh
foucault makes about descartes and
madness
oh that well let's think back to the
meditations
anyone who's listening to this who's
been through their intro to philosophy
knows that descartes goes all
through all the things that he could be
wrong about that introduce
doubt into thinking so when you're
dreaming
you think that you're using your senses
that you have a body that you're seeing
things
you wake up obviously you weren't
actually experiencing those things
so that introduces that little bit of
doubt into it
and then uh descartes i'm going to be
confusing descartes and daredevil
all day but descartes also gives these
the big d is yeah gives a mention to
madness
and says also the mad don't know they're
mad but they think that they're seeing
things they think that they're wearing
clothes that they're not wearing they
think that they're experiencing things
that they're not actually experiencing
uh
but we aren't mad so we're not going to
look for the locus of indubitable
knowledge in the mad
or in dreaming people and of course
takes
issue with this and says descartes
is creating a binary between people who
dream
aka normal people and mad people
who are abnormal and he doesn't give
abnormal people the time of day
and derrida reads re-reads
descartes and says uh that wasn't what
he was saying at all so
you missed the point i wanted to
reference something that eric said
actually
so just let me go first air because i'm
referring to your approach this is the
most
tedious thing i'll ever say okay uh
because i also think that one of
foucault's criticisms in the book
uh is that darida from his perspective
is developing a monological concept of
reason and philosophy
right that essentially he's saying it
needs to be
subject focused and we need to strip
away everything that's associated with
intersubjectivity
culture tradition uh and for that matter
classical metaphysics like you're saying
pills you know all that stuff about
uh scholasticism stuff it has to come
purely from
the cartesian ego if it's going to be
rationally validated
uh avocado being very critical of the
whole paradigm of the philosophy of the
subject
as taking aim at him in part for this
monological
approach at least as he perceives it and
i think this is also important because
it's something that darida brings up in
the essay that
from his perspective descartes isn't
actually being modelogical since the
demon is also important
right yeah also to be to be fair or to
put it into perspective at least
is that these like derrida is really
only focusing on a few
pages of the history of madness where he
sees
like the entire point or essence of the
book encapsulated
because the parts about descartes in
history of madness do not take up a lot
of space
compared to the sort of breadth of the
whole work
but derrida focuses on these and builds
outwards and i believe
actually foucault hits him on this a
little bit is to say well you've really
focused on such a small
almost like side note to my whole
project
is just like this this interpretation of
descartes that i've done but uh
i mean that's that's darry does kind of
method right like he
finds a crack or a fissure and he sort
of
worms his way into it and and then like
sooner or later you find out that it's
actually runs straight to the heart of
the whole project
and that if you can get through it you
can sort of
really see what's going on all the
tensions and
the like main structuring
arguments that the whole work is based
on so really
we're just looking at a little bit of
the whole work
and then using that to view the whole
right yeah that's a difference
that i think if you read this if you
read this for the first time
and you don't know the method that
darida is obviously
already developing at this time is it
sounds nitpicky
because he points to this one passage
that foucault
blatantly misreads and then you might
think oh he's just
focusing on this part in order to
criticize his reading of another
philosopher
but the point that darida is actually
getting to is that the binary that
foucault
is working with is a historical
which means that it's metaphysical so
he's idealizing
and then reflecting on his own idealized
vision of something that comes from
outside of history
so daria hits him and hits him and hits
him i think it's like knockout round one
after two pages i was like well
this is right but he says this what's
being set up here
similar to what boudreau said last week
what he's setting up here is something
that speaks for all history
all time and foucault despite pretending
like he's taking a place as a subject in
history is not
he's defining all history in these
singular terms
and then saying that that existed the
whole time
and then yeah of course there he does
critique here is that
the binary that he's setting up he just
locks himself into
from the get-go from from page one he
never escapes it
and if i was if i had written a 673-page
book
and someone dismantled it in in 40 pages
like this i think i'd be
pretty pissed too yeah i mean yeah
that's that's there he does way right he
he
inhabits the text he gets at the schisms
and the
tensions and he has this way of taking
like brief
suggestions and then pushing them to
their
absolute limits and then through that he
exposes
these contradictions and these
irreconcilable intentions in the work
and this is the deconstructive method
that darida takes he does the same thing
to levy strauss he inhabits the work
and he pushes it like past itself in a
way and makes it almost eat itself
and it's really interesting because you
think well derrida has destroyed them
but then again derrida couldn't have
done this
if they didn't write these works so it's
kind of an ambiguous thing
like we need foucault we need levy
strauss
and in a way he's just saying like you
know these things i'm saying
they notice about their own texts
there's brief asides there's moments of
doubt where they actually express
these things that i'm latching onto and
just taking to their conclusion
and it's it's kind of a it's a
misunderstanding maybe of darida that
he's just critical
in a negative sense when he's really
he's very very affirmative
but he does it in a way that turns the
work against itself
and it really mirrors what he's saying
about foucault you know
you understand the central binary here
is between reason
and unreason speech and silence
logic and madness right they're they're
these these central binaries
that derrida locks into and you know
foucault's going to complain a little
bit that you know you know
it was it's like kind of like reason
madness and dreams you know like there's
certain
relationships to doubt and unreason that
i that you've glossed over but
but derrida's overall point is really
hits home because it takes yeah foucault
nine years or something to even muster a
response to this attack
so i want to stress one thing because we
haven't talked about
derrida very often on here but one thing
that derrida
is far more aware of than anybody else
before him at least is that he's writing
and his text is historical but also
history everything that we know about
history
is textual so we have this back and
forth
being like you can never i mean we know
the quotation you can never escape the
text
there's not an outside text that you can
re-look at the text
from so he's very careful every time
we make broad statements we make grand
narrative statements we try to paint
all of history into a repression of
madness which is what foucault does in
this book
anytime you try to make your text
something besides
the historical book that you wrote in
1960
then he's going to take issue with it
and if you ever
this is why obviously dara is criticized
for
the reasons he's criticized being
there's no there's no comprehensive
truth that you can include all history
in
but every time you try to make these
massive claims
about world history he's going to be
there to be like
sorry you're writing a book in 1960 that
book can't do that
i wanted to follow up on that because i
absolutely think that that's right that
in addition to descartes there's kind of
a further specter uh that haunts both of
these works
uh which is the specter of hegel and the
dialectical tradition
because one of the things that vuco does
in this book
very brilliantly i'd say as he really is
very critical of
at least the classical dialectical
tradition which held that there's a kind
of
inner movement to history uh where
everything necessarily produces its
opposite
and this is how things move forward uh
because what you see
paradigmatically in this book and all of
other africa's other books
is this idea of breaks right that in one
era we conceived of madness
uh in this way and then we see the
emergence of modernity and rationalism
and we conceived of it in a very
different way right and what i actually
think
our daredevil accomplishes uh with this
text in a very prevalent way
uh is almost like a proto-negative
dialectical reversal
where he says if you actually read what
descartes is saying closely enough as
eric was pointing out
already from the very beginning of this
cartesian project the seed of doubt the
capacity for it to deconstruct itself
was latent within it because like i was
saying earlier
descartes actually isn't engaged in a
kind of modernological self-validating
project
that endorses an uncritical iteration of
reason
because there's always this specter of
the demon out there who's going to be
critiquing everything that we do
and what this demonstrates in the back
and forth between them is that from the
very beginning
the modernist enlightenment project had
the capacity to birth
a kind of hyper skepticism of reason
from the product productions of reason
itself
and this is something that's also going
to be picked up on by people like
nietzsche when he says christianity was
going to deconstruct itself
by heidegger when he says western
technology is going to deconstruct
itself
and now daredev as eric was pointing out
is pointing out that we need to
appreciate this dynamic going on
when we try to appreciate the cartesian
project and it's something that poco
can't do because he's so insistent on
periodizing a break between
the way we conceived of madness and
reason before and the way we conceive of
it
in the modern world and i find this
really very refreshing because i do
think footko sometimes
does tend to like to sharply demarcate
periods right there was pre-modernity
now modernity and now you know whatever
it is that we're entering
into after um and one of the reasons
he's attractive to many people is
precisely because he does have these
nice clear-cut
distinctions in history on a way
somebody like hegel or dick or sorry
dereda
do so that's just my take on this paper
but i really liked it i'm 100 proderado
in this one there's a
there's a great sentence it's just hegel
again always period
yeah true from derrida against foucault
saying yeah you're trying to get out of
hegel but you just did the same thing
again dude
yeah right it's that reason is a
totalizing sort of system right it's
it's hard to escape hagel because he's
he's systematized
everything in the bathroom sink and
foucault's kind of trying to do
something new but he gets caught up in
with there he does hegel's project
but i mean that there's a bracing
element to this writing a history
of madness right because if madness
cannot speak for itself
then how can you write a history of it
right so soon we learn that what
foucault is actually doing is an
archaeology
of madness right so then you you get the
difference between what a historian
maybe does what foucault does a lot is
work in the archives with texts
or you go to the sites and you excavate
and you dig
and instead of reading you have to look
at the traces
and the marks and you have to look at
the physical
you know the the physical archive rather
than the uh textual
archive as maybe derrida would later
sort of call it which is another kind of
text really you're playing
you're you're giving up one text for
another but for some reason
in in foucault's mind archaeology this
method of excavation from the history
is a better way of talking about silence
because when we get into the classical
age of reason
which i i believe like i'm not sure of
the whole
turns of the argument but this classical
age of reason was resurrected
in the medieval era and really again
with
descartes i'm guessing and the idea is
that
reason excludes madness here and and i
don't know we can
look at the quote that darida
points out that foucault is interpreting
in descartes
right so after that paragraph pills
described about
the senses being deceptive so why would
we trust something that has deceived us
before
but he says it may be that although the
senses sometimes deceive us
concerning things that are hardly
perceptible or very far away
there are many others that we cannot
reasonably doubt how could i doubt
that my hands and my body are mine were
it not perhaps that i compare myself to
certain persons devoid of sense
whose cerebellar are troubled and
clouded by violent vapors of black bile
he's using hippocratic language to
describe madness here
says these people they this is the key
thing they are mad
and i should not be any less the insane
were i to follow examples so extravagant
and he's talking about like crazy people
you know
who think they're pumpkins or think
they're made of glass
who think they're kings when they're
really poppers and that sort of thing
and
and descartes kind of himself he sets up
a question here
it's like okay so from a reasoned
perspective
the senses deceive me so sometimes
so why would i trust something that's
deceived me before
but then i look at these crazy people
and i think
but i don't want to be like them either
thinking that i'm made of glass
or thinking i can have out of body
experiences or whatever else
these people think so where does that
leave us
and foucault has one way of interpreting
this and derrida
you know throws shade at that big time
so let's go back to the beginning we're
we're kind of
we're kind of hasty that's that's just
the descartes moment right that foucault
picks up on and that dairy dove zones in
on right
right at the beginning um i just want to
here's here's
foucault's sort of motive is that in
the history of philosophy reason has
always been spoken for
and it's always philosophers as speaking
subjects
that are saying here's the reasonable
way and they say
what's rational by contrasting it
with what's insane so that's what he
what descartes did
in his mind he said while i'm on my way
to finding the thing that can't be
doubted
um step two basically is going to be
throwing
crazy people aside because obviously
they're not rational
then the whole rest of the foucault book
is saying
uh or tracing a history an archaeology
of
here's where we privileged
we could say privileged rationality
over insanity and insanity is
always being pushed aside the secondary
term so doing an archaeology
is is foucault putting himself
up there saying i'm going to speak for
the silent because the
the crazies have always been silenced
and i'm going to speak for them now
now the very first objection to that the
very first objection to that
from darida is if you're going to write
your book in the french academy to a
whole bunch of other french academics
that's not the cr that's not you
speaking for the crazy people
unless you are just reintroducing
the same binary that exists between
crazy not crazy
and obviously that darida would never
contend that that that
distinction is not contingent because it
is contingent
but foucault writing his 673-page book
about it
is actually just re-silencing
the crazy discourse by turning it into
philosophy
and then he says even worse this is i
think just page three or so
then you're romanticizing it you're
romanticizing unreason
the way that the romantics or the way
that nietzsche did
i do want to defend foucault a little
bit in part just to have some spice with
this because i think we all agree
that this is a great paper and on the
point about descartes it's kind of a
knock down blow
right uh that you know credit card
reason isn't self-validating or
monological and it always contain the
seeds of its own kind of deconstruction
right
uh but one of the things i don't think
you find in this paper or really as
present uh in darita's work as a whole
that you do find
very vividly and very powerfully infuko
including in this book uh is an account
of knowledge power
and the actual material consequences for
the victims
of this kind of bifurcation because this
is a kind of dialogue
about descartes but it's a very minor
part of the book what's a huge part of
this book is an account
frankly how it is that so-called mad
houses or insane asylums or sanatoriums
are created
and the really horrible things that they
did to people in there
and it's presented in a very affective
way bifocal where he says look
what the psychiatrist assumed they had
the right to do
was to decide not just who is has a
medical problem which isn't such a bad
thing
they made themselves the arbiters of
what is epistemically correct
and they can essentially say that your
brain doesn't function properly enough
because you just don't see the way that
the world really is
uh and they were able to get
institutional validation for this
right uh and to coercively apply
their standards to pretty much the rest
of the world at least the west
the rest of the western world and i do
think that that's a really powerful
kind of description of something that
occurred
that you miss uh if you just focus on
these philosophical points
and i think it's important to foreground
that since as pill said to me uh last
week you know
to be a leftist is to be a materialist
and foucault i think is a somewhat
better materialist in his account of
madness
uh than somebody like darida is at least
on the subject
as a whole yeah we should i mean yeah
being
being compassionate towards people with
mental illness
i mean that i mean that's that's the
least philosophical way i would probably
put the point of foucault's text because
before this right and maybe in the
metaphysical
sort of perspective you know madness was
always viewed
i mean i don't know about the divine
part but always as a moral failing
upon the individual yeah and this is why
i like
delusion guterree so much on this point
as well
is that madness and deviance are
actually
social diseases that we can address and
that don't
implicate the individual in a certain
way right like they're diseases of
capitalism they're diseases of industry
and institutionalization
more so than they are like these people
just need to be contained like in bedlam
where they would just chain people to
the walls right like that
that was a horrible way i think even on
a basic level we can say that's a
horrible way
of dealing with people who are having
these kinds of difficulties
but that was the normalized kind of
approach
and i mean it's hard to emphasize how
like crude medicine was even
at the time derrida and foucault were
writing it was pretty crude
it was full of snobs it was careerist
and
it was just all around horrible and we
shouldn't ever treat people that way
neither in our philosophies nor in our
daily lives it's crazy
is the ques so i'm curious so is the
main critique then so i think like we
can all agree with
what matt and eric just said you know
about being compassionate to
meant to mental illness but then like
the critique that darren is launching
here
right is it not just at its essence like
a critique of as pills said at the
beginning right it's like oh you claim
you're like escaping certain binaries or
metaphysics but you're actually not
you're doing metaphysics and it's like
i mean if if that's right then like i
guess the other
question might be uh like from the
perspective of what eric and matt were
just talking about
like so who cares if you're doing
metaphysics yeah like like i guess so
what's like
like who cares like why is that an
important critique is the question
or worse is dairy does critique like
harmful to that project of
trying to be compassionate towards
people and
i think part of dairy does style is
maybe to avoid
something like that so i want to hear
pills on this from
this because i can see him i can see him
wincing a little bit well if
if you want if you want to do the boil
down critique that you just did that's
foucault saying we should be
compassionate to crazy people and again
every time we say crazy it's in
quotation marks that's what the
history of madness is about but then
someone else's
response to it would be in the exactly
same oversimplified
extremely crude summary is
then why are you writing philosophical
papers about it
right yeah right okay sure i agree but i
mean
it's worth noting that vico was actually
quite a bit of an activist scholar
throughout his life not always with the
best clauses it's worth noting there is
nothing outside the text
yeah i don't think that any stuff so
it's i don't think any of us endorse
books you know
pro iran uh kind of flirtation for a
little while there but you know people
pointed out that this was
uh the book that made him famous and
part of it was because as eric said
uh for a long time mental illness had
been seen as some kind of
cognitive defect uh you know in some
senses people would say
you're being infantilized if you have a
mental illness and the fact that he was
willing
not to necessarily speak on behalf of
these people but
at least raise the prospect that
something bad was happening to them
i think was really in some ways
materially innovative even if it's
philosophically flawed in the ways that
daredevil is talking about
as we're done in the book he says look
i'm not trying uh as daredevil says to
romanticize madness
or to suggest that there aren't some
people frankly have very serious medical
issues
uh that need to be treated what i'm just
trying to say
as eric put it is that chaining people
up onto walls
and saying there's something wrong with
the way you see the world
and we cannot abide that in our society
and either you need to change to our way
of thinking about things
uh or we're going to put you aside and
not allow you to join civil society
that's wrong right i know fukuoka
doesn't use that word but that's the
kind of ethos that comes from the book
and if it kind of overemphasizes the
point in the 1960s
which i think it does i think maybe it
needed to be overemphasized in this
point
just because so many people took the
opposite tact for such a long
period of time right yeah you can see
the kind of influence of it like
as you mentioned you know ken one flew
over the cuckoo's nest the ken kenzie
kessie text right this really had a
revolutionary impact on culture culture
where people all of a sudden
from novelist to to liz would say things
like look why shouldn't we think of
aberrational ways of thinking is maybe
having something to offer
why should we treat this as a cognitive
deviance uh rather than maybe just a
distinct way of apprehending the world
that has something we could learn from
right so it does open a kind of door to
have a dialogue about this at least
i mean you you say that and now you're
presenting foucault
as some kind of activist but as as you
well know he never says what to do about
it
he he knows like a good nachian that
that would be moralizing and that's kind
of at the root of the problem here
don't look at me i'm just a historian
but that's the bad
philosophical position in this case if
if this
is actually a text about we should not
treat people this way
then derida would not be deconstructing
it because he only deconstructs
philosophical texts that you know
maintain a facade
as if there's a center that were that
we're being true to
when there isn't one there or when you
you enable a contradiction
yeah that's the thing madness is a
philosophically interesting concept
and the idea that rationality excludes
the madness points to the idea that
you know capitalism or modern philosophy
or
af post-industrial revolution you know
that that language of rationality
is part of our institutional realities
right like these psychiatrists and all
this juridical language
that cements our laws and the ways we
treat deviants
it's all in there so foucault's attempt
to find
not a history but an archaeology this
attempt to
find a method that evades the sort of
logic
or language of reason and order
is a philosophically important venture
because you know if you like too often
if you
if you are like radically
anti-capitalist
or you're an activist of any kind you
can be labeled as crazy as
mad as insane and it's just a kind of
it's kind of like a dog whistle to say
that this person
is not compliant this person is
threatening the investments in our
institutions and our social orders and
this person needs to be stopped so
it is philosophically interesting to try
and find a language of how to talk about
madness and that is i think derrida's
exact
point is that foucault has initiated
this enterprise yeah in a way he's also
failed spectacularly because his
archaeology i mean it's got
logos right in there does it really
evade the problems that he sees with
writing a
quote-unquote history which would use
the logic of order
what we were saying before you know the
language of order dividing
periodizing making nice divisions
i i agree 100 percent the one thing that
i'm going to foreground
just you know in part to be a [ __ ]
disturber because i think we need some
back and forth on this or we'll all just
agree with darada
is i do think that foucault is much
stronger uh in looking at the kind of
material instantiations of these forms
of knowledge power to use his preferred
term
than dara does and one of the problems
that i have with a lot of deredus texts
is
brilliant as they are at locating those
cracks and the philosophical edifice
you don't always see as much material
analysis power dynamics
or as much talk about how it is that
certain kinds of human subjects are
created by knowledge power
as you do in foucault so i would say
that in some ways
we do need a bit of foucault with our
derrida uh otherwise we move too
close to just talking about descartes
and thinking we can read the history
of the institutionalization of madness
through an interpretation of how it is
that cartesianism is spread
through our culture this echoes what uh
we read last week with beaudorado saying
you're just reflecting capital you're
reflecting the totalization of capital
dairy dot what is this 15 years before
writes uh the infinite complicity in
which
foucault compromises all those who
understand
their own language is basically the same
thing
you can only denounce power from within
power and by doing that you're
reasserting the same thing
so i wanted to introduce i mean we've
talked we talked about it a lot
last week as well but like delusion
guitarist anti-oedipus
on schizophrenia that is a
far better way to deal with
uh madness as we would call it
madness instead of saying we're gonna
romanticize this and call these people
victims anti-oedipus offers a model by
which norm deviance is
creative and productive and i think
daridal would have been much more on
board i mean he probably read it i have
never read him
saying that he read it but he'd be much
more on board with that kind of approach
than foucault's pseudo-structural
i'm going to map out the history of
knowledge and then read
things misread things so that they fit
the narrative
that i want to present which is these
people are victims
but no we should go back to the original
madness the wild madness of the greeks
and derrida calls him out on that point
too saying oh you're just
you're doing the same thing that
nietzsche and heidegger did being we're
going to go back to the
original unity of of of the logos
where everything was happy and good so
there are ways to do this
while taking the seriousness of the
issue into account
when we're talking about bedlam or
whatever else but
or dario is taking specific issue with
foucault's
monolith his monolith institution
um i'm going to write this from the
university of paris
type type approach i'm going to write
the history of the world other history
of all of knowledge
and then derek asks him well you're
going to write the history of the origin
of history don't you understand
how that's contradictory so you're right
i think everything you're saying
we should listen to you say yes this is
this has
material functions that we're not the
dairy does not really pay attention to
but not and not really addressing but
what daridai is paying attention to
is if you're gonna write this way then
you're you're building up the thing that
you're trying to tear down with your
other hand
yeah if there's something you don't want
to talk about origins with
it's definitely derrida and you have the
rk
in archaeology right like we get words
like archetype
from that as well it's a kind of origin
and at the same time
yeah the the leader of the old greek uh
models of civilization and yeah you
really
don't the first but it also means the
dominant it means both of those
yeah the premise the alpha like you
don't want to have those conversations
with derrida because he'll just shut you
right down
but i think some of derry derrida's
critique is wrapped up
in the sorts of ways of foucault's
expression and the conceits
of foucault's work as well because
foucault's writing
madness is the subject of the book so
he's going to speak about it but it's
also the subject in the sense that he
wants madness to speak
he wants to get it to be a first-person
narrator
in a sense in his book and this is a
very strange conceit
and derrida notices that it comes out in
sort of two ways
that foucault sometimes avoids
using the language of reason and order
because
in the institutional history of madness
those are going to be connected with
psychiatry
psychiatric medicine and they're going
to be connected with theories of the
body politic
and so he wants to avoid those in
getting madness to speak for itself
and the second conceit is that he
thematically connects madness
with silence which brings up the other
problem of how do you get something
which is silent to speak
which that without immediately entering
into
again the language of order and reason
so foucault's trying to write an
archaeology of silence
and dary does questioning whether
foucault is always successful at
avoiding the language of order
and escaping juridical and psychiatric
language
and whether getting madness to speak
saying that madness at some point in
history the origin of
madness's silence is that reason tossed
it out
of the philosophical city and said
you're on your own now
the darida kind of says you know
foucault's not
very successful in framing that darida
actually points to
a secondary project that actually
emerges
behind foucault's work and it's to look
at the root
of both madness and reason in the greek
logos
and to question whether it was the greek
logos that instituted
that that this difference that decision
as you'll call it in the first place
that separation of reason for madness
did
did the greek logos instituted and when
i say greek logos i'm really just
talking about plato and socrates
or did was the greek logos the original
ground
which would mean that it's not the
origin then reason and madness were
divided at some later point afterwards
and in terms of this is galaxy brained
as hell
but in terms of the way that foucault is
expressing his whole idea of getting
madness to speak for itself this is a
philosophical problem because it gets to
the heart of the philosophy of language
and deconstruction that darida
takes through his whole career right and
i do want to stress
just because our audience may not be
familiar um
it sounds like fuco is just getting
eaten alive here
but we have to remember this is only
the 1960
book um that we're we're addressing here
he addresses a lot of the
contentions that we're making in order
of things and
archaeology of knowledge later on which
are kind of answers to this
yeah i want to say i do actually think
that vuco at his heart
is a foundationalist of a certain sort
in a way that daredevil never could be
and in fact he doesn't quite state as
such uh state
um that as such uh in the order of
things becomes very close
so the order of things is probably his
most important
um methodological book that in the
archaeology of knowledge which is its
direct sequel
and one of the things that he says in
the order of things is that
from now on history is going to operate
as a kind of ore science
which can arbitrate between all the
other different kinds of knowledge
because
it takes a quasi-dispassionate view and
can look at all of them
at the same time in a way that they can
he later backs away from that strong
claim in the archaeology of knowledge
correctly right i think because he's
aware of the implications of where he's
going with that
and then later on in discipline and
punish he says
i'm not going to really engage in this
archaeology archaeological project any
longer because it's
too removed from material analysis
interestingly enough
to my point so now instead i'm going to
be a genealogist
in a nichian framework and i'm going to
be talking about the material
instantiations
of various forms of knowledge or power
uh in disciplinary institutions
and interpret uh modernity in that way
but what's interesting about whether it
is whether you're doing an
archaeology of knowledge uh or a
genealogical examination of knowledge
power in its material instantiations
is that he still can't get away from
this idea that history is the or science
some kind of fukodi in history and i
don't want to be too critical of him
here because nobody wrote histories like
foucault
right uh you'll never pick up a book uh
like madness and civilization and
discipline and punish again
it's very creative very original very
innovative but if you're determined to
be an anti-foundationalist i don't think
he's the one that you want to go with um
as eric and pills both said uh anytime
you start talking about urge origins or
foundationalism or
sciences or whatever they're going to
come after you and they do so rightfully
uh in this instance but i think the
switch there
that you mentioned from archaeology to
genealogy was in response to
a critique like this because uh
derrida and baudrillard are
fundamentally saying the same thing
about foucault
and i think there's a quote in here
where darida says this book is a
gesture of internment so exactly the
opposite if you're hoping for
liberation he's saying no you're locking
you're locking everyone down
into either the position the position of
complicity
either you're complicit with repressing
badness
or you're the mad who are repressed and
i was reading this
and uh i'm also i'm almost loath to
bring it up
but it's pretty much the uh jordan
peterson critique
of foucault is that it's made to make
make
everybody feel guilty or and everybody
else
victims but this is 1963
and uh derrida said the same thing
you're you're interning
everybody as either a perpetrator of
violence
or someone who violence is being done to
and you can't speak
but then you're going to speak for them
and then darida goes no no you can't do
that because speaking for them is the
same violence that you're critiquing
by putting it in a knowledge structure
so when foucault says i'm going to go
from knowledge structure to just tracing
the genealogy of knowledge power
then he's trying to get out of that
knowledge structure whether that's
successful
or not we'll leave for another day
beaujohart obviously thought it was not
you're just replacing a new science
system there i'm going to say though i
do think that this becomes a prevailing
problem
for derivative analysis going forward uh
so probably
the paradigmatic paper in this vein uh
is actually post colonial theories uh
it's gayatri spivaku was a deridian uh
paper can the sub alternate speak
and her kind of conclusion is no we
can't right
any time somebody presupposes that they
can speak for the sub-altern
uh they're of course taking their voice
away from them to put it really very
simply right
uh and so therefore uh we can't ever
engage in these kind of essentialistic
projects uh of
deciding that this person or this figure
or this group of figures even
uh can speak for a marginalized group
since that of course uh
silences other people uh who might
belong to that group
even talking about this group is
problematic the difficulty with that guy
actually that spivaker selfic knowledge
by the time she gets to 1997's
critique of postcolonial reason which is
a very difficult this uh sorry difficult
book
is look if we can never allow anyone to
speak for these groups
then nothing is going to ever get done
right nobody is going to start our
undertaking the critical project uh
since nobody's going to want to speak on
behalf of anything
uh so then she starts to argue for
strategic essentialism as she talks
about it right
i will claim to be able to speak on
behalf of x
even acknowledging the fact that i might
not necessarily have that right for
political purposes
right so i do think the deridium project
winds up in a bind
as well down the line uh that's
interesting we could focus on that as
well because i also uh
wrote a footnote in my notes to this
because she was responding to criticism
of her work
so can the sub alternate speak where she
is speaking for the subaltern
then saying that the subaltern can't
speak and i think this is the kind of
thing yeah this is this is actually a
crucial point where we have
like theory what can you say about
history what can you say about text
and then oh if we're gonna be true to
not being originary not being uh
totalitarian
with our ideas then there's millions of
people living people who are trying to
live their lives that are going to be
left behind but then the question comes
back to what tereda says in this book
what does writing a university paper or
a book
a 673-page book what does that do
except change the minds maybe change the
minds or just invoke responses from
other people that are at the sorbonne or
the the
the collage de france yeah i agree with
that but i mean
this problem of essentialism uh and the
subaltern becomes a major issue for
deridium theory
and more than just an academic kind of
context right say i were to carry a
placard
and march down the street rage now
saying you know no justice for palestine
right um i'm essentially speaking on
behalf of a subaltern that i've assumed
to have a certain knowledge for
they're not present can't speak for
themselves highly problematic in a lot
of ways especially
as a western trained academic who's ever
been to the middle east
however right um a certain kind of
strategic essentialism in this kind of
circumstance
might be useful uh since by assuming
that i can at least
infer certain things about what's going
on there and how the people as a whole
are responding to it
i might be able to agitate for a
constructive political change
by going and holding that placard up in
front of queen's park or whatever
right uh and if i just were to sit there
and say i have no right to do that
uh then what i'm gonna end up doing is
just staying at home and playing
warhammer total world 2
in anticipation of warhammer total war 3
coming out soon right
so i think that there's a bind that we
find ourselves in here too that's not
just an intellectual one it's also
very adamantly political since you can
raise these kind of anti-essential
points
about any kind of political activism not
just intellectual political activism
yeah i think it's a really important
point here because the idea of
archaeology
as speaking for madness but also being a
way to get madness to speak
and being against reason and order
language
i mean derrida asks a question like
when's the responsibility
of archaeology and that's the central
question here responsibility
being able to speak for somebody else
but also
you know have that little dash in there
response ability
someone up being able to also speak back
to speak for themselves to leave room
for
a continuing dialogue and a response
in essence right that continuing
relationship rather than just speaking
for somebody and then that being the end
of it you're their representative
they're the they've delegated all agency
to you
to speak on behalf of them that's the
question of archaeology here
can archaeology escape the
history which is you know a language of
order
can it really do that darida seems to
think no because he says
an archaeology against reason doubtless
cannot be written
for despite all appearances to the
contrary the concept of history has
always been a rational one
it is the meaning of history or archaea
that
should have been questioned first so
he's saying you know he almost wants
like a prologue
a prologue like a question of like
what will our method be before we
proceed
he wants foucault he's almost like
writing that for foucault
and then later on he says well actually
now this second project emerges but
here it's it's a writing that exceeds by
questioning them the values of origin
reason and history they cannot be
contained within the metaphysical
closure
of an archaeology that's that's dairy
does kind of just saying
this this can't be done you've you've
failed to live up to your own project
here
but i mean like i don't think he
acknowledges that later on though
which is why the genealogical transition
happens right like he
gives up on this project eventually yeah
so it's always weird
the roots and the ways that we come to
take in the criticisms that people lay
out against us
it's kind of strange because we kind of
have to come to them ourselves and i
guess foucault is like that he's a bit
combative
so he never takes it in he always
responds
and rebuffs but then later on it's like
he starts thinking uh yeah okay i can
work this in somehow and then
and then by a circuitous route he ends
up actually taking on the criticisms
that were
initially launched against him after
ignoring them for 20 years speaking of
which after speaking of palestine
because de luz supported palestinian
resistance fukuda and talked to him
for 20 years as well
really uh it's a girl was a
never-ending story a cat fight that's
why it makes a good series yeah
he was a touchy man it never ends but
yeah i i mean i'm picturing
derrida is like derrida gray walking
into
foucault the white's tower of discourse
and saying
when did foucault rise abandoned reason
for
madness and then like all that goes down
then darry does gets
launched to the top of the tower did you
see that there's another quotation in
here where he said um
this this book was foucault writing for
himself
to not go mad he was writing against the
the fear of going mad
or something i didn't know that that's
funny i like it makes my quote
oprah apropos like i just want to say
like about pop culture references right
like
i do understand what he's saying though
uh dared about you know these kind of
cheesy western people who will
assume that they can speak for whatever
you want to call the sub-altern
uh people in developing countries you
know whatever um
you know you think about like those
crappy 80s pop songs you know where bono
and michael jackson would get together
and be like we've never been to africa
but we do know that it's really poor so
we're gonna sing we are the world
and that'll make everything better we'll
just have a raw concert
um you know this kind of activity is
extremely insulting
and very patronizing to these people on
their lived experiences
right so i do think it's important to
point out that that's not what we should
be doing we shouldn't be romanticizing
the mad
romanticizing people living in other
countries in precarious conditions
whatever
i just think it's too much to go the
opposite direction say that wow we
should just
sit there and endlessly think about what
the right way to speak for them will be
rather than actually doing something but
that isn't the critique we're kind of
we're kind of bastardizing it to the
point where it's not even correct
anymore
i know well now i'm just talking about
crappy 80s pop songs because i want to
bring that up
but what dario's objection is just to
restate it is that
you're re-inturning that distinction
you're recreating that distinction and
even assuming that that distinction
occurred in baker or cartesian
philosophy
saying look we can point to it okay now
we have an enemy
it's descartes and anyone who follows
descartes now we have everybody on that
side
now i'm going to be the virtuous
philosopher and go to the other side and
speak for the silent
and daredevil's point is you're not
doing that you're not doing the thing
that you're saying you're doing
yeah i told you i completely agree with
this paper and his criticism right i
think that
any reading of descartes that's actually
moderately charitable will showcase that
he's not a monological figure who says
that reason is self-validating and it
all needs to come from
the subjective cartesian ego uh right
from the very get-go as
daredev points out uh there was the
possibility of deconstructing this
project since
descartes foregrounds uh the possibility
of skepticism towards reason
very very prominently and this just gets
effaced in this pakodian history
and you know fair enough but if you keep
focusing on the descartes part then
you're still going to miss the point of
why derrida is bringing up descartes
i'm there's a there's a lot of relevant
references to this
in terms of the way that scholarship is
done today and even just like
uh non-academic discourse but
when it concerns total power structures
like uh
patriarchy or capitalism
then they're presented also in such a
way where
you must take the rk side
or not but if you if you instead if you
give people
only that choice like you're either on
one side of this binary
or the other the binary itself is the
thing that never
comes into question and you see this
misreading
when when we say all of all of history
is this
like descartes been accused of a bunch
of different things but it could be like
descartes used only masculine pronouns
so he's a member of the patriarchy he's
reinstantiating it
in the same way that foucault reads
misreads
sorry descartes on madness this is a way
that scholarship is done now
following foucault saying you're on the
bad side of the binary and i am on the
good side of it
and that is the the crux of what this
article is arguing against
so i think it has a lot more to say than
even what we've we've brought up so far
in if you if you estab or establish
re-establish the binary and put yourself
on the good side
then you're complicit in that thing
existing and it's not like we can all be
diridians because there wouldn't be
enough time
but that criticism holds well to
a lot of the things that we talk about
in terms of colonialism would be another
one it's just like this er
giant unstoppable force when if you look
down
every reality like that every reality
that presents itself is total
always has its cracks in it it always
has opportunities for resistance
um it's just that i don't know
creativity is at an all-time low now so
i don't think that's as fun as trying to
try to own people okay i 100 agree that
i mean i know a lot of them and i know
uh victor does also right there are a
lot of [ __ ] out there there are a
dime a dozen
who do adopt this kind of victim
oppressor binary um
go straight from these kind of texts and
say you're on the good side or the bad
side so let's be on the good side and
speak for the people on the good side
a hundred percent i do just want to say
though that i don't think that that is
for cow's approach
because he makes it very clear uh even
in this text that he's not trying to
actually romanticize madness
in the way that dario does accusing him
it's not a very compelling response
right now but later on as his work
develops by the time you get to
the late period he says look the entire
thing that i'm trying to get across is
that power
pervades all the different social
relations which is problematic for the
reasons beau jr points out in our
discussion last week
uh but you know we can have productive
forms of power that also exist that
allow us to create
new subjectivities you know new kinds of
modes of life
uh that won't necessarily be as
determined
uh by these disciplinary forms of power
uh that force us to inhabit
subjectivities that we don't wish to
right uh and i do think that this is
more emancipatory uh and less binary
uh than the kind of people who've
appropriated for kodian tropes
in his name right um so let's bash on
all the shitty fukudians out there but
at least acknowledge that
the man himself uh seemed to be
cognizant of some of these problems
and did respond to them throughout the
course dude no this is not a knock
against foucaultians this is derrida's
knock
against foucault that we just read it's
already in there
so whether or not he changed it up or
whether or not he responded 15 years
later after the fact
is a different story i'm not poisoning
the well here this is what
daredev saw there right off the bat yeah
i mean i don't know if this is too
simplistic
but what i see happening here and what
pills was saying with the
kind of the bastardized kind of binarism
that some foucaultians adopt
like derry does points i'm not even
saying foucaultians just dividing people
into the a people
and the b people the b people are bad
because they have power
the a people are good because they don't
have power b
exploits a were on the side of a
so we are thus good as well
yeah i mean sure those people like they
had their window open it was windy and a
few pages of what is an author blew in
or whatever and and now they have this
this whole scale interpretation of
history and everything else
like what dairy does pointing out here
is that neither reason
nor nor madness are
neither is more original than the other
because whenever you have a binary right
you have to look at the difference you
have to get between them
and talk about difference i mean this is
exactly what heidegger does with the
ontological difference
right it's not that the antic is more
important or the ontological is more
important the important point is the
ontological difference what that points
to is that there must be
a more original ground on which that
difference
was launched or instituted or made
right because when we try to point out
one as being
the original and the other one as being
the derivative
the unmarked one of the binary right the
mark or the marked side of the binary
the marked is different the difference
itself is what's important and that's
why hence
dairy does you know de ferrance right it
also kind of has a temporal dimension to
it as well not just a distinction but
it's there's there's a more original
ground
on which the difference is made and
that's where we have to get to and
foucault's kind of there at the
threshold
saying you know there was a distinction
a decision
made to cast out madness
from the city of philosophical reason
what dairy does trying to take it a step
further and say that that difference
itself
has a ground and that's where we have to
get to we have to get back
even further so that the binary again
doesn't just become
this unexamined given that it's
also something contingent and we have to
move through it
in order to get to it so that and
archaeology doesn't do that archaeology
just reproduces
exactly what it seeks to evade which is
again reason order and the language
of logos and it does that precisely
by pointing to decision you kind of
glossed over the word but it's really
important
is that you look you look back in
history
to when the decision was made for
whatever the decision
for when when men were superior to women
and then that was the case forever
after that or whatever whatever
oppression version
uh colonizers colonized and for darada
that's
the error that archaeology
makes it's saying let's look for the
decision because that's the moment
when everything changed when every
everything orbits that decision moment
so if you can find it
in this case if we can find it in
descartes then we can you know
speak for the side of the oppressed and
it's really important
yeah for derrida to say that decision
is not real that's part of
you privilize or privileging history as
this
sequence of events as if that's what
happened that there's one decision
and if we could go back there and undo
that bad thing that we did
then everything would be gone and that's
just not the case
so i do want to push back on this a
little bit by saying that
i absolutely agree that that would stare
that's what dara does are trying to do
uh but it's not like he hasn't had his
interpreters who've read a philosophy of
history
a kind of cheesy philosophy of history
into his own work you could find
people who will say that the whole
history of for instance western or
european philosophy
is just a logocentric mistake that we
now need to overcome
which is similarly reductive right uh
and it's important to note that
every now and then daredevil does write
as if that is the case in
of grammatology right where he's talking
about the problems of the metaphysics of
presence uh
and why we need to now wean ourselves
off uh these kind of ontological
conceits which is a pointy picks up from
heidegger as you point out so i think we
can forgive foucault occasionally
lapsing in uh to these kinds of problems
because it's not like darada and i think
daredevil was more aware about this
uh was immune from giving in to these
kinds of
structuralist or trans-historical or
ultra-historical temptations
okay you're wrong sorry this is
important though you're reading the
conclusion as if it were the method and
the critique of presence
is not historicized that's why he reads
texts
particular texts heidegger did that yeah
i grant you that but darada
does not historicize so sir
i think when he's critiquing the
metaphysics of presence
i think he absolutely did i mean if you
read of grammatology
there's a very clear philosophy of
history that's genu that's genetics it's
not a philosophy of history he reads
individual texts and points out the
presents in each one that's it
it's a yeah but again i think that it's
very easy to read a philosophy of
history into that and people have since
then
well then they have but he didn't write
it in there
yeah but again this is the point that
i'm trying to get at right voco has
sometimes been misinterpreted as
effectively a structuralist thinker
who's
reading these binaries into everything
when the reality is because he did
you read the same article i did i think
that if you were to look at of
grammatology
you can kind of see the heideggerian
history of metaphysics
uh latent within it and it's not
very difficult to interpret the book in
that way
and so what i'm trying to point out is
that the same way that
foco wasn't entirely able to wean
himself off of these temptations
or difficulties neither was darada right
the whole history of a metaphysics of
presence right is a very grandiose idea
that's very easy it's not even a
critique you're not even giving me
anything to look at you're just
generalizing a text about someone who's
always very specific
okay well then i'll give you a very
clear example right uh so he points out
that the metaphysics of presence
uh and the supposition uh that there has
to be something here
uh is always latent in many different
particularly modern philosophical
thinkers right and what's always being
excluded by this of course
is all the potential things that could
deconstruct what's present
and demonstrate that it's essentially
withholding
uh something important that might
actually tell us a lot more
about how the world actually is if you
want to call it that or the more
interesting way to look at the text uh
if you prefer the part laws
uh and this has begun very much a
heidigarian project where heidegger will
say things like
if you look at the kind of history of
being
from plato going forward uh what we see
is a gradual forgetting of the
ontological question
in favor of trying to assert that being
is something right
being is mind or being as spirit or
being is history
right uh all of which is about
yeah absolutely i mean so what i'm
trying to say is that this kind of
history of philosophy that heidegger
developed
is mapped into the kind of history of
logocentrism and the metaphysical
presence that you see in daredevil which
daredevil
yeah which he does critique yeah but
what i'm just trying to say
is that like it's not like he was
incapable of making
very broad very sweeping statements
about the history you're still
confusing a methodology with his
laboriously drawn conclusions and taking
one for the other
even when he's 33 darida is not
one to make broad statements about
history he absolutely did
what else are you going to talk about
when you talk about a metaphysics of
presence right that's the conclusion not
the method
i mean here's here's bringing it back
right what metaphysics
when darida gets his hands on it it's a
critique of
this distinction between presence and
absence
and presence is the valued side of the
binary and absent or
absence sorry is is the unvalued
the marked side right the origin is
always
absent but the way that metaphysics
works is it's a little bit like
ideology it covers up its own origins
right it covers up the way that it works
and just makes you think that the given
this binary distinction
with the valued and the unvalued side is
all that we have to work with
it goes back to that right so i think
what derrida
is doing here is is pointing that out in
foucault
and saying we need to be aware of this
and then let's push this in
a little bit further and so he calls for
a new project that locates the original
ground
that united reason and madness in the
first place in which that decision
that foucault points out could actually
take root in the first place and he says
the attempt to write the history of the
decision division
difference runs the risk of construing
the division as an event
or a structure subsequent to the unity
of an original presence
thereby confirming metaphysics in its
fundamental operation
and i think he's saying that metaphysics
kind of covers itself up as it presents
itself to us
right like the metaphysics of presence
is the same thing as saying speech
is better than words written on a piece
of paper right
i read a book and i want to know what it
means i interpret it and
we disagree so let's go ask the author
let's bring the author here and the
author can speak and the author is the
authority on their text
again that's a that's accepting this
metaphysical binary
that writing is less valuable than
speech
that presence is more authoritative than
absence
but the absence part is what derrida and
that's exactly what i'm saying just like
he focuses on
right there are a million doridians out
there i can think of who would
spit back is a very good example right
who will sit there and say look
when we look at the history of
metaphysic of western metaphysics and
this idea
of presence and absence right uh what is
considered to be present
is always given a privileged position in
positions and systems of power
so therefore we should probably take the
side of what's being
repressed if you want to use this no we
should not probably take a side you're
trying to both sides
when the topic of this freaking article
is how one correctly points out that
that is what the other is yes
yes and you're just doing the bad
reading now that you say
bad deredians are doing okay and
precisely the mistake
is that you can never invert an binary
to undo the decision yeah taking the
side of i guess
code does that literally with madness
hello everyone i'm an archaeologist and
today i'm going to speak for madness
i'm going to make it the privileged term
now i don't i don't care
if jordan peterson or you misrepresented
me
you're just yesterday oh it's all right
because everybody's inconsistent
but no he isn't yes but what i'm saying
is people make exactly the same
accusations toward daredevil later on
right that's so what is just about
heideggerian history written with a kind
of
acknowledgement of cesarean linguistics
and it really is as behold into the
history of idealism
as heidegger's history of metaphysics is
and i don't think that that's a fair
criticism it's not a fair criticism
but what i'm just why are you even
bringing it up i know it's saying that
because i'm just saying that
we can give foucault a pass for
sometimes writing in a certain way
uh that would lead to these kinds of bad
interpretations that you're talking
about and in the same way
we should appreciate that daredevil
could sometimes write in a way
that can and has led to people
interpreting in a similarly bad way
right so i'm just saying let's not be
but
are you saying that foucault is just
that that it's only because of the way
foucault wrote but not his intention i
mean i thought
there was an establishment that foucault
actually made some philosophical errors
here and like wasn't
wasn't actually achieving what he said
he was going to achieve whereas darida i
mean
the claim is like i'm as i've been
pretty silent here because i just don't
know darren did that well so i don't
have him like i can't really speak that
much to him but i know that
um the claim it sounds like what pills
is saying is like you know he's actually
always
been true to his method so like people
may misinterpret him but he didn't he
didn't make any errors because he
achieved what he said he was trying to
achieve at least that's the claim well i
don't necessarily think that that's
entirely fair though
again because if you look at madness and
civilization right again
the accusation that epico is
romanticizing the mad
or setting up a binary where we should
take the side of the victim against
so-called oppressors right uh it's
something that he's very explicit we
should not do
right he says in the intro we need
i am going to here speak for the silent
yeah he's going to speak for the silent
but that doesn't necessarily mean
endorsing the views of the
what is essentially saying is that
there's been a privileged history that's
been
given thus far it's a history of reason
and reasons triumph and now i'm going to
show how it is that a system of power
was set up
that created this kind of perv this kind
of outlook
and then be critical of it right but
that doesn't mean that we should
necessarily take the side of the mad
against
the defenders of so-called reason it's
just to recognize that
this binary is highly problematic as a
system of
power and domination right and i think
again if you look at the way that darida
approaches the history of presence and
the metaphysics of presence
in of gramatology there is sometimes a
binary at work that you could similarly
exploit for political purposes by saying
that
oh darida is taking the side of
women and femininity uh against
masculinity and
toxic conceptions of masculinity which
many feminist theories have tried to do
right
i think that that's a misreading of what
dared is trying to accomplish
right since the point isn't a privilege
one side of this binary over the other
but it does sometimes lend itself to
that interpretation
in the same way reading madness and
civilization would lend itself to the
interpretation oh foucault wants us all
to go
drop acid and be crazy for a couple of
hours as fun as that might be right so
i'm just trying if anything to say
if we're going to give dare like
foucault [ __ ] for
sometimes writing in this way that would
lend itself to as you yourself put it
bills these bad interpretations
right we should also acknowledge that
there are a lot of bad interpretations
of darada out there
and if you were to read of gramatology
carelessly enough
it would lend itself and has lent itself
to those bad interpretations as well
that sure was a lot of words um i'm i
think i've said my piece on this and i
don't want to belabor it anymore
uh eric
oh i think foucault certainly is going
to claim that derrida misread him
and misread his interpretation of
descartes
and shouldn't have focused on that in
the first place which we'll have to see
next week can i can i just ask a
question though here about uh
like you know i mean i feel a bit like
uh you know that i felt feel a little
bit like that kid in the class who
didn't do his homework because i just do
not know darren's philosophy well enough
and like you know just reading this one
paper wasn't really enough for me to
but i'm but i'm curious like you know i
mean i've heard i've read this a couple
times
uh like or i've heard i've read about
this a couple times right this kind of
like
deconstruction of binaries as being kind
of one of the the
touchstones of darida's thinking and i
mean maybe this is unanswerable right
now but you know what's
i mean i guess it just seems like as
someone who doesn't know daryl like kind
of just like
an obvious thing that like binaries are
bad that they can be distorting
of reality that they like can kind of
can kind of like guide us
in to like kind of simplifying and uh
you know kind of obfuscating thinking
so like but i guess so like what's novel
about
like i mean is it just the method with
which he does it with like his kind of
deconstructive
tactic where he reveals the
inconsistencies of the binaries
yeah i mean i don't know how to give it
a really
sort of straightforward because yeah
it's not straightforward derrida avoids
taking positions that's the sort of
point of deconstruction but i think the
idea is that
when you write something in a
structuralist vein you think that
afterwards once you've set up all the
binaries
once you've made all the distinctions
once you've erected the structure
that's the explanatory apparatus and
then now there's some other object which
that explains
and what derrida does is he goes the
opposite direction
and he shows you that how when we we
look at a structure
say you go outside and you look at a
building and you assume that oh that
must have like a center of force
a center of gravity and all of those
binaries and all of those relationships
that are holding together are actually
all fixed
by this center of the structure and what
deconstruction does is it goes
and it shows you how each binary depends
on another one depends on another one
depends on another one until you get to
a point
where okay there must be a center to all
of this and then you go there and look
and behold there is no center
it's an aporia it's a fiction in a way
and so in a sense what happens during
the time you're erecting one of these
explanatory apparatuses
is the thing that you think is doing the
explanation at some point
becomes the thing that needs to be
explained
and darida points out that moment and
you see that moment
in archaeology the method itself
it reveals and in this passage which
condenses the entire essence of the work
there he does claims
this passage on descartes that foucault
writes this condenses that entire
structure
into this central point and then derrida
looks at it
and says the center is not the center
the center is actually outside of the
structure it's somewhere else
which is why he says that we need this
new project
of locating this original ground and
then when we get
where reason and madness came from in
the first place and then likely
once we get there if we could locate
this original ground whether it's in
classical philosophy
or whether it's in the pre-socratics
those things that
nietzsche and heidegger were so
interested in whether it's there
whether we get there we'll probably find
that there's no center there either
and it becomes this endlessly referring
sort of structure
that deacon and the deconstructive
method is meant to
reveal that get behind it get under it
and
restore the sort of
explanatory apparatus to the position
clearly of the thing that actually needs
to be explained right
so what's the relationship between that
approach which seems to not want to take
a stance on anything right and kind of
reveal how like fundamentally the
categories we use
the binaries we use are just
self-referential to other binaries that
rely on other binaries which ultimately
leads to like an emporia
you know i guess it's just so what's the
you know
is there a what's the relationship
between that and praxis or action
eric i first of all i thought that was a
brilliant explanation thank you
um but when it comes to practice i think
darida better than anybody
knows what he is he's a french
intellectual
studying history studying the history of
thought
in an institution and that's the thing
that he writes about so
later on when in the 90s he does move
more towards practice when he's writing
about
uh hospitality and things like that
but at the basic term the the huge
problem
with which i think eric did a great job
of explaining is when you build when you
have a binary you say this binary is bad
then you just flip it over then you have
a brick
and then you just add more bricks to
that so then you're just developing an
anti-system
that in every way is eventually going to
resemble the thing that you're trying to
replace the thing you're trying to fix
right so when you're trying to say
we can't read dead white males
in universities we should have a class
that's exactly
all non-white males to like counter
balance them
yeah i guess that would i mean i think
that might be a crude example because i
could see i can see
you tile ways of using that but if you
build a system that's exactly the old
system
on its head you're still not getting to
the distinction the orbit
that those things are built on and then
you have other things that are built on
those distinctions so he says
in uh the essay right before this one in
this book
uh writing a difference that all of
philosophy
is basically a history of light because
the light
the plato's cave metaphor light was the
very first
distinction darkness is bad darkness is
in
ignorance light is knowledge light is
good
keep in mind there that he's not saying
history is a history of light
but the history of written textual
philosophy
now we have this original metaphor that
does not
occur in the world but in text
and then the rest of text is added to
onto that
elaborating the first metaphor and then
light becomes associated you know in
enlightenment
with rationality reason intelligibility
clarity and so on then when it comes to
practice
um derek is mostly quiet on that
and again to reiterate the reason is
because i think he knows what he's doing
he's a writer
of books dealing with other books
and i think asking the question of
practice is not at all
a bad question but it's it's saying your
your practice that is not writing books
is going to be different from your
practice of writing books so
i think this we could even bring this
back to the
mentioning mcluhan a whole bunch of
times you me he knows
what his medium is and he knows what
foucault's
medium is but foucault doesn't know what
foucault's medium is
foucault thinks he's being an activist
and a philosopher at the same time and i
think that's where dereta goes
you're crossing you're crossing paths in
your own
brain and it's not working because
you're not doing one
or the other when you think you're doing
both so i'll give you a
bad deridian interpretation of uh bad
fat
radiant feminist take uh of the sort
that i was being critical of versus a
good one judith butler's right
a bad deridium feminist take uh would
say something exactly on the lines of
what
pills and eric are talking about right
uh that through the history of western
thought what we've seen
is the privileging of a masculist
viewpoint uh over a feminine one
right uh so in order to overcome this
kind of dilemma what we need to do is
re-emphasize the position
of women and their kind of distinct
outlook on the worlds
right uh that'd be a very classical way
of misreading somebody like daryda
right exactly the way that pills was
talking about a good reading though
uh would be somebody like uh judith
butler's in gender trouble where she
draws directly on daredevil by saying
the problem with doing exactly that uh
is
as pills was saying uh what you
essentially allow yourself to do
is let patriarchy decide
how it is uh that you're going to
express your femininity because you're
just
expressing it in response to the
presence of patriarchy in your society
and in the history of western thought
right so you haven't actually overcome
patriarchy all that you've done is allow
it to determine
your responsiveness to it uh so the more
truly feminist act
wouldn't be to foreground the position
of women relative to men
uh but to try to deconstruct the gender
binary
as a whole which is of course what she
does in gender trouble by saying
why do we need to have a masculine
perspective or feminine perspective
uh why can't we just see gender as
something that's entirely performative
right uh the result right right i get
that i get i get that in like you know i
mean the one thing about gender trouble
though it's as much as
it's as much of a deridian book as it is
a lacanian book to some extent which is
kind of a structuralist view too so kind
of i mean i think maybe that complicates
the story like slightly just because she
i don't think that that judith butler is
committed to deconstruction right i mean
she's got like a quite but but in any
case
the reason is the gender binary practice
practical side to it but the
the gender binary thing is interesting
but i mean the thing is i always find
like you know getting beyond binaries
it's like i think i
it just sometimes seems to me that um
like there's a kind of um uh paralysis
that can occur when you just when you
when you can't talk about
when you can't use words to talk about
things anymore because
they will invoke some binary and it's
like it's just it becomes sometimes it
can become absurd
but these bad as you say versions of of
like
being skeptical of whatever binary it's
like okay well we can't describe
anything because it's going to invoke
and we have to stay pure
away from these we have to like stay in
somaphoria because we can't fall into
these
binaries that lead into anything it just
kind of feels like it can lead to kind
of paralysis and
like which again seems to interfere with
praxis is kind of where i'm getting at
i mean yeah it's hard even when language
is
implicated though though we don't have
to be overly concerned about the
signification of words
at all times though it's just as a
philosopher who's trying to write
something about what's true
non-arbitrarily that's a specialized
kind of language
so if you want to be some sort of
activist then do that on your own time
you know it's a separate
aim the medium of that type of speech is
not concerned
with what's non-arbitrarily true at
least not
primarily so to go back to last week
this whole may 68 thing is how do we
how do we do politics once the french
marxist
party has failed at politics
do we just rebuild the new new french
marxist
party or do we act as philosophers on
one hand
and then be activists on another hand
and darada is very
clear i think about saying when you're
writing
philosophically specifically then you
don't want to
re-instantiate the thing that you're
trying to
undermine while you're trying to
undermine it
if you're doing a different kind of
writing then you're probably doing
something different if you're writing a
manifesto
you're not doing philosophy in that way
but
what darida deconstructs is always
these these non-self-conscious
writings of histories that find origins
that find kernels that are never
questioned
that's always the thing that he reads
he's not reading like
the newspaper and deconstructing it
right yeah yeah
i do think that this is a problem though
go ahead eric you can go
i was just going to say i think another
interesting example might be the
sort of theism atheism binary yeah
because
when you had atheism coming around in
the 20th century i mean i'll just start
the story with the you know the four
horsemen of the of
new atheism right like how can someone
like jordan peterson who's clearly not
an atheist
like coexist with them on the i on idw
so comfortably because all he's really
doing is just
again just reversing that same binary
that the atheists originally reversed
right
like science the coming of science means
the
fading of relevance of religious
institutions and religions so let's all
be atheists and science will get us
there
and then by the time of the new atheists
that position is extremely solidified
but it's simplistic it's just
emphasizing the other side of the binary
and it just reflects the structure of
theism
and then all you have to do to be jordan
peterson
is to come around and say the same
things that they are but just flip the
binary again
and you don't have anything new
happening because they haven't
deconstructed
the position in the first place they've
just reversed it
and now they're selling books like mad
and banking on it
it's another maybe another yeah there uh
deridian could uh maybe have a field day
with that one too i do want to say
though victor i i actually agree with
you which is
kind of what i was getting to you in the
middle of this before we went on a kind
of
attack on daredevil i would not have
that discussion but like
i do think that there are limitations to
this approach to things
uh because i think i'm more hostile to
it than someone like pills is uh and one
of the limitations is political which i
think even durians acknowledge today
people like spivak right
and for that matter as you pointed out
butler like who gradually kind of moved
away
uh from a more deridian uh to a kind of
more psychoanalytic perspective
uh and it precisely uh is this right
that if we can't necessarily assume to
speak on behalf of some kind of a
centralized
identity category women men you know
colonized colonizer whatever right
uh it makes it very much difficult to
mobilize uh on behalf of
constructed political projects uh and
this is something that
you know people like martha nosebaum and
catherine mckinnon would point out right
uh if the category of woman becomes so
erased in somebody like judith butler's
work
how is it that we can even have a
feminist movement any longer right what
is it even speaking
well could also could and you know i
think we all love zizek and we're all
sympathetic to leukemian psychoanalysis
and obviously we're like i mean we're
already at an hour 35 minutes by the way
but
you know i'd be interested uh to know
like uh how can
like kind of a geridian approach to
philosophy also coexist with the
lacanian approach which seems to me to
be quite structural
and uh built on a number of binaries but
uh i don't know
and i was already thinking i was already
thinking not with
lacanian psychoanalysis but with post
frankfurt school critical theories that
the reason that darida occupies such a
different
sort of area of critical theory is
because there is not
like an explicit politics there whereas
in the frankfurt school critical theory
there is an explicit politics and it's
very explicit
but with even with someone like yeah so
i'll give you that that yeah
politically it could be a problem
post-structuralism has
tendencies towards a kind of political
quietism not that foucault
really has a much better politics being
as
like structuralism and linguistics in
general
does not have a much better politics
than post-structuralism does
so i mean yeah you can argue that
derrida
doesn't really have an explicit politics
and he really does try later as
pills was pointing out to have a more
sort of active approach
to his concepts like ethics hospitality
and
responsibility but you know take that
for what it is you're totally racialists
don't seem to either so it's not really
a point for foucault either
no you're right you're right that uh
that i think foucault also can lead to
kind of quietism
as well just as just as nihilism or kind
of that
endlessly referring winding structure it
doesn't lead to any sorts of
concrete conclusions i mean isn't this
kind of a problem with uh with some
like maybe this isn't like a kind of uh
thing that seems to be
a recurring thing in some kind of
continental what we'd call continental
approaches to
philosophy or metaphysics to like it can
because it's so fixated on trying to
push the limits of like of
all concepts and all stabilizing kind of
points of reference like they always
want to trouble every single archimedean
point of reference
that i think inevitably they sometimes
end up leading to this kind of like what
the [ __ ] do we do now i mean it is a
destruction of tradition
the main gesture is against that
stability because that stability always
ends up being coercive though so the
reason that they can't
get to something like that is they don't
want to reintroduce
coercion into their social structure
yeah i mean i
i will just say quickly that i i don't
you know i'm not really i get that
that's the reason why
these continental approaches are doing
it i understand that the intention is
behind like
this fear of of the authoritarianism of
categories and all this stuff but i
guess i'm you know i'm not all that
convinced uh
i think there's alternatives to just uh
trying to
you know like uh eliminate and be stay
pure from any sort of arc
archimedean point of there's a way i
guess i guess like you know if i was to
sort of off the cuff say what like what
i think my approach these kinds of
things is it's like
you just have to treat these points of
reference as much more contingent
and kind of open to revision uh that's
that seems like
and use them but just they're always
open to question always open a revision
as opposed to just being like well i
have to try to escape them
yeah that's beaujard's claim too just to
re-bring it up is if you tr if you're so
against
stability that you say this is all flows
it's all difference we can't
like get our hands on anything solid we
just need to keep exchanging things
then you're just mirroring capital two
so
if you go too far the other direction
you're in exactly the same wash
anyway we have to call it there uh it's
yeah it's been no molar get ready it's
been a long one
um i don't know if if you go i thought
this was a knockout i thought this was a
round one knockout and then he kept
beating on him for another
uh 38 pages but uh
what what did you guys think did we was
this a knockout or
are we being too hard
i mean i think it's based on the
criteria for which he was
critiquing him like i think it probably
i mean it was i mean i think it seemed
right to me that he didn't that
he identified the ways in which foucault
wasn't doing what he said he was doing
like or wasn't achieving that that end
goal i think that's right
to me it's like when when uh foucault is
standing in front of the enemy and he's
fighting him and the enemy is reason
and then derrida comes up behind
foucault and just sort of skewers them
both at the same time with the same
sword and was just like thanks foucault
you did half the work for me here's the
finishing blow
totally and boom so foucault you know
like he gets so much credit for it
but it yeah i think it's it's pretty
devastating
as well but i would i wouldn't say
foucault is
i mean foucault's still like the sort of
mountain you have to climb before you
slide down the daridian fun slide on the
other side
all right well um i've never read
foucault's response to this uh but we
are going to read it for
next week so until then
peace out from the pill pod take it easy
don't binary
later
bye fire and brimstone
[Music]
fatality